hello and welcome to this video on
playing Sudan 84 okay played one game
against him that I lost don't have any a
particular memory about that so let's
see a plate 93 g3 what kind of a profile
is such okay I am played with Bishop g4
he's six that's a fairly common line but
he's avoiding to play c6 which is
interesting they normally always plays
his six maybe he's doing it now yeah
indeed he does that's him
I should have five kind of uncommon
hmm interesting
interesting way to play Bishop f5 at
Queen c8 covering p7 my display later
eform first I'm trying to kick this way
I can actually take on f5 take on f5
take B 397 shake take 1 C 8 a 1 a 1
that's a bit crazy
technically speaking it works I think so
I'm going to take the you should pair
here you will take Queen f5
93 I should be material up
maybe I'm wrong and he can't trap the
night but he also needs to spend one
move for the night a one to move if I
move my Bishop M so and was to be
expected but no I have gained the bishop
am for nothing much
I wonder if d4 is a move here for black
no didn't do it okay e4 was on my agenda
anyway and it gets stronger now that
there is no light squared bishop anymore
for black that i have the bishop here in
addition to that ruling pawn Center it's
a very nice position for white that's on
the agenda
anyway let's play it another pawn roller
efore f4 this is one of the ideas of
this whole variation with the trade on
d5 that you get an extra pawn on the
King side or center and then you get
this to move I'm currently threatening
to play f5 Queen h5 Bishop f3 resigns
Queen strapped yeah but how does that
help you how does it help him
that's it queen is gone yeah that was a
pretty good good position for a white
after I could take on f5 as really a key
moment of this game um so here I think
it's fairly equal this pollution maybe
not a six and went to t4 I think you
should just retreat the bishop now
probably to g6 and then we continue I
was intending to play a form in this
position I have to be sure about it yeah
that there's nothing happening with the
unprotected tonight but I don't see it
at the moment the engine gives this as
an idea it's interesting looking at this
pawn and this is probably what should
happen after this I mean it's
interesting maybe I was wrong there but
I don't think he can take here right
this doesn't work I check here take here
he takes here and I can evacuate tonight
and I have two pieces against the rook
and a completely overwhelming position
on top and he also has to still save
this line which will probably work but
it just doesn't yeah it's just a bad
position but surprised that it's on
let's plus 4 I plus 4 is drastic I mean
it is it looks like a win to me but plus
4 is really drastic
okay Queen f5 is the only move I left a
Quincy to maybe you should think about
playing d4 in this position really not
certain of this move you know because I
mean I either have to go back which is
not so ideal even though this is
definitely a route that makes some sense
or coke or cohere and except then I get
a double to e pawn this is however not a
big problem like if you take that for
example and I still have F
five and potentially III to get rid of
the double pawn that also looks like why
does at least a bit better you know
after that before and now he has to
avoid the Queen trap which is definitely
possible interesting that the engine
wants to go before him first
oh there is a tactic here
what is the tactic I sorry I misread the
the email Bishop d6 that is interesting
there is a pin of course and they have
no f5 yeah would be embarrassing
interesting so after here here like it's
actually quite okay because I don't have
a clear way forward I am okay and this
is probably why the engine wants to play
before at some stage so that the knight
has to retreat first like this going for
here yeah that's probably true
and after this I'm already already
winning and there is no satisfactory way
to play this is avoiding the immediate
loss of the Queen but after f5 g5 and
looks rotten I thought h4 maybe but he v
e5 is also terrible what kind of
position is that yeah it's just lost for
black yeah this whole line it has a fair
amount of fair amount of
you have poisonous quality that say it's
also easy for black to handle this even
though it doesn't look dangerous at
first sight thanks a lot for watching